so John what did you think of ant-man
and the wasp it was okay so Chris what
did you think of ant-man and the wasp
okay so ant-man and the wasp has been
released to the theaters and we got a
chance to see it I actually saw it kind
of early and with you yeah last week and
this is gonna be a spoiler review
totally spoiler filled and we're gonna
get in-depth about everything it happens
in the film and stuff that we were both
little confused about but this stuff we
liked because I mean like I said I do
think the movie is OK it's not one of
the better Marvel films that's for sure
I like the first ant-man a lot more I
definitely did too I think the first one
just from a screenplay is much stronger
movie building off of infinity war which
i think is a movie we both really like
this film it just it felt sort of like
filler to me when compared to that film
yeah infinity war is sort of like a
steak dinner and then a mana wasp is
sort of like a hamburger from the
McDonald's dollar menu that's
interesting comparison and I think for
some though that's okay which is fine it
felt very much so like an extra thing
and the two ant-man movies kind of rely
on that they sort of hang on to the
coattails of a bigger more epic Marvel
movie and get the aftermath that's
exactly what happened with the first one
which came out after age of Ultron
you're right yeah it did and this one
you know after infinity war in so I
think it's kind of a marketing tactic
from Marvel's standpoint where they're
like we're gonna release a literally
smaller-scale movie after like this big
epic film and people will feel sort of
like it's refreshing and and like a
change of pace 20 years from now
nobody's gonna care about when this
movie came out they're just going to
watch the film and judge it on its own
merit so I don't really think the film
is any better simply because it comes
out after infinity war in fact if
anything it looks worse to me because I
really did like infinity war and this
movie feels sort of like almost like a
TV episode in the end
you like it might belong and one of the
Netflix shows but with obviously it has
a higher budget yeah it's like you said
it feels like part of a TV show it feels
like a fragment and I didn't really feel
like you compare to the last three or
four Marvel films that have come out
black panther Avengers infinity war thor
ragnarok yeah this movie compared to all
those is definitely the the weakest link
and it's strange because a lot of the
more praiseworthy reviews are using that
exact comparison but as a way to say
it's good like this is different and
better and smaller and that's why it's
better but I think that's kind of what
Marvel is hoping and again that's fine
like honestly like if you loved ant-man
the wasp that's cool like I I didn't
hate it as I said I feel like it's it's
kind of stupid that I feel like we had
to keep saying that like we didn't hate
this movie like we have to continuously
defend ourselves
for thinking that a Marvel movie was
just fine yeah I gave it you know a
slightly negative grade and I had to
defend myself I was scared I said sorry
when I was done and it is just which is
unnecessary well it's just because I you
know we've been doing this for a couple
years and you can predict the outcome of
a lot of situations so I like to save
myself the time and hassle commenting
back and you know are in the reviewer
like I'm sorry I'm sorry I thought the
movie was media I know you're right
you're big I'm small I'm dumb you're
smart no more yeah yeah yeah H I think
that's from Matilda a notice it is heavy
Gamora
it's Adam Sandler I'll put a clip right
now I'm stupid you're smart I was wrong
you were right you're the best
I'm the worst you're very good-looking
I'm not attractive actually Chris you
might want to find the clip from the
movie Matilda because I think it's in
there as well maybe I'm wrong listen you
a little wiseacre I'm smart you're dumb
I'm big you're little I'm right you're
wrong and there's nothing you could do
about it
when I did my my spoiler free review I'm
gonna tell you guys this right now I
actually did three cuts of that review
wow that's intense yeah I saw it on June
26th I could have posted it on June 27th
I waited til July 4th because I kept
trying to figure out how I could discuss
my
biggest issue of the film and I can't
because it's filled with spoilers and so
I just kept I hated every cut I did the
first cut I was like ah that just seems
so just I'm not getting my point across
the second cut was a little better and
then I got to the third and I was like
okay that's about as close as I can get
to expressing that pretty much
everything surrounding Janet and the
finality with that character just felt
so underutilized and kind of thrown away
but the MCU movies have had a history of
having a rough time with villains this
year has been pretty good actually kill
monger was awesome Thanos was the best
probably that Marvel has had so far and
so when we come to Walter Goggins as guy
in suit who wants technology and ghost
girl who can face and is mad about what
happened to her in the past and then you
sort of start to understand why she's
mad and then she's not even intimidating
and Walter Goggins is basically just
there so they can have a car chase with
some Expendables and not worry about
like any of them whom that might get
killed or something he's just in this
mood to be cannon fodder I mean it felt
like the performance he gave in this
movie is the same performance he's given
in every single quittin Tarantino movie
he's been in for the last five years
Django hateful eight he's doing the
exact same accent like a southern evil
guy has some kind of scheme he almost
feel like an afterthought because the
main villain or if you can even call her
a villain his ghost and she's weak at
that and I it almost felt like when they
went back in they said that's not enough
of a villain we need to add another
element there to chase the the
protagonist of the film maybe they just
tagged him in yeah I was more interested
in the past stories that are set up
Michael Douglas and Laurence Fishburne
their characters confrontation they used
to have like when they met and they were
at odds I was like I'd like to learn
more about that story actually or Janet
and them in the past like the past d
aging CGI is incredible and I found
myself more invested in those stories
but they were pushed to the side so
often for more screen time with ghost
and Walton Goggins and I found those
characters very forgettable oh they were
completely disposable I mean they were
more disposable than the villain in the
first ant-man Yellow Jacket who was the
most generic bald douche bag corporate
bad guy you could come up with he
disintegrated
Lam's what's the matter kid never had
lamb chops all that being said I think
my favorite parts of the film was wasp I
do think that she's really badass and I
love Evangeline Lilly as that character
she's definitely like a big highlight of
the film and you can tell they really
were designing the film around her
character and as a result Scott kind of
gets pushed into the background which
that doesn't really bother me he had his
own big movie and throughout all of
ant-man one of the big continuing
storylines was that wasp was frustrated
with not being able to go out into
action and so it makes sense that she
would kind of take the forefront in this
movie like with the after credits scene
of the first film she finds her suit and
it kind of sets that up but as a result
Scott he kind of comes off like an idiot
in this film they keep making him do
stupid things and make dumb choices and
he doesn't really feel like a hero and
they kind of retconned a lot of his
smarts like in the first film he's super
clever he breaks into Hank PEM's house
and so doing he impresses Hank which is
why he gets the job as ant-man and in
this film he's just kind of like the
funny guy yeah I mean even in the first
film he took down Falcon on his first
outing essentially and in this movie
he's kind of like he's like a bumbling
sidekick yeah instead of the hero of the
movie yeah and I'm fine if he doesn't
have as much like screen time for
something but just don't change the
character like one of the things I loved
about the first was that dynamic between
Scott and hope the fact that they were
both actually pretty good at what they
did and so they kind of butted heads a
little bit and in this film it's like
know Scott's kind of stupid and wasp is
amazing and that dynamic is gone as a
result she's so fully formed as a hero
one of the central questions in the
movie I think from her is do I need a
partner and and if so do I need Scott
Lang is my partner there were moments in
the film Rose like hang on a minute guys
you're not really being fair to Ed man
cuz he's pretty kick eyes like come on
give him give him a break
I like rhino Park a lot but in this
movie I think his character was a little
much for me he did kind of feel like a
cartoon guy he was constantly trying to
catch Scott in the act of getting out of
house arrest and when he showed up he
would just have like some strange joke
to say and I just
it just felt awkward to me it didn't
feel like it landed he almost had an
infatuated with the character of Scott
and he wanted to hang out with them a
lot which could be funny but it just
wasn't played well I don't think it was
the right character for that the shtick
got old quick is the runtime of the
movie kept progressing yeah I think my
favorite aspect of this movie was
probably the father-daughter
relationship I thought his daughter was
adorable they achieved that emotion
really well I think but the other
emotional part of the film and really as
we said the whole point of the story is
Janet now this is what I wanted to get
into in my spoiler free review but I
can't and it's really my biggest issue
with the film so for a couple years now
there have been speculation videos
theory articles about how Janet could
have possibly survived in the first
ant-man you actually even see for one
frame when Scott gets stuck in the
quantum realm you see a little image of
the wasp in there like a little shadow
so a lot of people speculated how could
she survive it's been 30 years has time
stopped for her will she have not aged
has she found civilization there like in
the comics it's known as the Microverse
and there's this whole other thing
called the micronauts but since the MCU
doesn't have the rights though that they
can't call up the Microverse there are
civilizations there there's a place
called homeworld you know there's all
this stuff in the comics that you can
look at and say well that's what she's
been doing that's how she's been eating
or drinking or whatever the people had
theories for years you know how did this
happen and I actually read an interview
with the executive producer of the film
and this is on screen rant calm they
asked Steven Broussard will you explain
how she's been aging how did she eat how
did she stay alive he says we will
definitely get into all those questions
that's part of the questions that our
heroes have it's such a the mission so
to speak is kind of this wing and a
prayer this mission of faith that
they're hoping she's down there kind of
thing as they go on it and they have
those same questions what has life been
like for her you know they ask is she
all there she's been alone for 30 years
he replies excellent questions so him
telling Screen Rant that they would
definitely answer all those questions I
mean they don't this is my biggest issue
at the film
janet is there she's in a different
outfit she has aged she possesses Scot
she shows him dreamlike visions she
completely takes over his body and and
operates machinery as him and says I've
had a long time to think about this so
time did not stop for her she's got
makeup on mascara like all this stuff
eyeliner yeah they never ask her what
she's been doing
they never address what she's been doing
you never learned what she's been doing
and they certainly don't answer the
questions as that producer said they do
there's really just one line in the film
when Hank rescues Janet and she looks at
him and says it's about adaptation and
evolution possibly suggesting she's
adapted to her environment or even
evolved into something else but that's
about as deep as we get one sentence in
which were left with tons of questions
and I don't really think the types of
questions the film should leave you with
this isn't the season finale to a show
we like in which we're gonna get the
answers in the following season it's
ant-man and the wasp it's supposed to
feel like it's its own thing and in the
after credits scene Janet mentions to
Scott that there are these things that
are cute but don't mess with them
because they'll eat you and that's
pretty much the gist of what we
understand and we do see some entities
trying to attack Hank for a moment and
so we understand that things are alive
down there it's just that they don't
delve into it at all
as far as all the theory videos go for
the last couple of years and in between
the first movie in this movie it sounds
like they put more thought into it then
the actual screenwriters of this film
did they did another thing is that she
has like magic powers now ghost phases
you know and she's she's all tortured by
it and she just walks up to ghosts and
fixes it somehow there's never a scene
of any kind that explains this we just
are supposed to accept it because this
is part of an episodic series or
whatever and they'll explain it another
movie but in the after credits scene she
gets dusted by Thanos so does Hank Pym
listen everyone
since after watching this movie the car
ride home this is what we talked about
for 45 minutes the notes really didn't
bothering you Chris but I would say this
in the Marvel Universe
anything that can't happen it will
happen we have Infinity stones little
stones that control the fate of
humanity's or do whatever you need them
to do yeah so it's got people flying we
have gods we have lightnings monsters
quantum realm goes magic magic I guess
your makeup will stay on intact maybe
she's been down there watching movies
it's just it felt so lazy
it does feel lazy there's definitely a
void in the script of this movie and it
could have easily been explained or
another easy out could have been time
for her stop
Sochi for her she's only been in this
paradox for 20 minutes yeah not 30 years
that would have been the easier way to
go I don't know why they didn't simply
do that I know exactly why they didn't
do it because then she would look young
and Hank looks old and that would be
creepy it just seems like they want
everything to be perfect you know like
there's Janet she she's been in this
quantum realm for 30 years and she's not
stark raving mad Tom Hanks was on an
island for four years and when he got
back he saw a plate of lobster and
almost had a nervous breakdown she spent
in some weird space right through
quantum ground for three decades wasn't
there a line by Michael Douglas in the
first film where he mentions the quantum
realm and he says there's nothing down
there nothing he says it's like the
concepts that we're used to mean nothing
down okay well the thing is it wouldn't
be that big of a deal if it was like a
five-minute subplot of the movie but the
entire movie is a rescue mission you got
to retrieve her you got it yeah it's
it's lazy it's lazy and it's irritating
and it's kind of like an insult to the
viewer who watches a movie for two hours
and they don't care enough about your
intelligence to at least give you a
better understanding of what they've
been presenting to you for two hours in
a movie yeah so it starts off in the
next Avengers with you see Scott's stuck
in the quantum realm maybe he's down
there talking to somebody maybe maybe
showcases how it works it could and that
could yeah that could answer things it's
just it's just that when it comes to
this film it's it just feels like it
needs this I mean you said it yourself
this movie is relying on the fact that
not like the Avengers that it's not a
big film that it's it's connected but it
feels separate if you need the the next
Avengers film to explain it away well
then it's not a small scale as you might
think
sure yeah and you know the other thing
is I don't want the next Avengers film
to take it's time to explain something
exactly easily been explained in two
minutes in this mood exactly
literally all that could have done is
had Hank like zap into there and he's
just like holy and you see like
this little world and she walks out of
it and she says goodbye to people that
she's been down there for thirty years
and then she goes by the way when I was
possessing your friend Scott when he was
taking a bath and he had that dream that
was weird yeah yeah I almost imagined
the quantum realm like the scene in
beetlejuice resetting the waiting room
and they have tickets to be called up
you know the other weird thing I have
with the ant-man movie especially this
one I and it's maybe it's a Marvel thing
the color grading in this movie it sort
of makes me tired when I watch the movie
nothing really pops to me it kind of
just looks a little washed out or blown
out for the most part throughout the
movie that's one of things I love about
Ragnarok yeah it was completely
different yes living this colors yeah
this movie kind of just dull they've
kind of taken this specific color
grading tactic for every earth MCU movie
I call it concrete that's actually
really good everything looks like gray
concrete but there's one more thing we
have to talk about Chris and the Marvel
Universe is infamous for this the after
credits scenes all right we've already
talked about the one where everyone gets
dusted but the most phenomenal one the
one that really sets this one apart and
just lead you into the next upcoming
huge Marvel film I can't wait
I'm just getting goosebumps talking
about it it's when you have the aunt
playing rock band
we waited 10 minutes to see that by the
way that was in the trailer it was yeah
it was yeah huh yeah well not that
important I guess not really I remember
we sat there and we
like it's got one shot of an ant playing
drums yeah we could have done anything
as far as the character ant-man goes I
love it I think Paul Rudd's phenomenon
the role I think the movies are okay
they're disposable movies in the Marvel
Universe and that's fine because you
need those in between the bigger movies
that's great but this film it didn't
feel like it used all that much
creativity the simplest things could
have been explained but the the script
writing was so lazy they just said that
tomorrow vote people will assume and
they don't care and that's I just find
that somewhat insulting that that's my
biggest gripe with the movie I do too
like film like Justice League slapped
together movie with like a billion
reshoots that was also in my opinion
kind of mediocre even that movie
explained how they brought Superman back
from wherever he was they did and
there's one thing they did but I mean
like this movie doesn't even try to do
that with Janet we just have to accept
it like imagine if in Justice League
Batman's like I'm looking for Superman
he's goes I'm here and that's it and
he's wearing eyeliner
ha ha ha ha ha ha so yeah Ant Man and
the wasp is fine if you liked the first
one you might think this one's fine too
I like the first one a lot more
I just keep bringing myself back to she
possessed Paul Rudd for a scene like
wait what maybe the movie should have
ended with an exorcism
[Laughter]
well guys please do check out my buddy
the flick pick John Flickinger his
channel loads of great content thank you
for joining me once again for a fun
video it's always fun
I like getting together and complaining
about movies as usual hey you know we
got together we talked about movie
that's not total
this one we're always talking about bye
bye man and like we talked about a
movie that isn't complete yeah
truth or dare and then we go to ant-man
on the wasp you're right we talked about
movie that ain't mediocre but not
yes all right fair enough good
that's fine we've made progress today
you did guys thank you so much as always
for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here
get stuck mine eyes by the way you
notice we have like insect related
movies in our shot don't ask me why I
own a lick yeah I just you know that's
whatever I'm gonna borrow this actually
anyone watch it have fun yeah
[Music]